hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to life after us the system
does it look like I've completely given
up on life with my hair if so you are
way too concerned with my hair but this
is a horror game that I saw the yamimash
played and a lot of people suggested to
me and I'm finally bow I have been
tasked with retrieving the granddaughter
of mrs. Hemington I have been told the
girl is in her late 20s but due to her
mental illness she has the mind of a
child she is believed to have returned
to Hawthorne sanitarium where she was
once a patient I will search the asylum
for a girl in return her safe mmm
investigator going into asylum alone
where paranormal activities are sure to
rain this seems awfully familiar with
many other things that I played I made a
new friend today dr. Tarr he says I'm
very pretty he kept touching my hair you
must really like it oh so it's gonna be
that kind of an asylum and that kind of
a horror story really well abuse runs
rampant
oh good blood I was wondering when there
was gonna be more blood mr. Teddy should
be here
okay among the sleep I don't like it
here a mean woman took mr. Teddy away
she said I'm too old for silly things
like toys he's not a toys my best friend
I can't sleep without mr. teddy I wish
someone would bring him back
I need him next to my bed is that why
blood went everywhere because you killed
the nurse who took your teddy away you
crazy little girl even though you're not
a little girl
at least that's not a cliche of the
horror games you are a perfectly grown
adult with a mind of a child and
probably supernatural power whoa that is
a fast print I must say this game does
look good as per usual some of these
games that I played made on you mr.
Teddy oh you're so cute hi you're coming
with me I need to put you by a bed I
think I'm pretty sure that's what I'm
supposed to do the mouse is very very
agile here mr. Tony don't mind the blood
I'm sure it's perfectly normal
what what what are you talking about I
blackout an upon waking I find myself
still in the asylum but something is
wrong the darkness surrounds me and I
feel as if I am not alone
I must find the girl as soon as I can
well okay I put mr. Teddy down and then
I take a nap because I'm crazy and
belong in the asylum to stay forever
oh hello good morning everybody
is it still psychotic in here good dr.
Tarr told me I'm very pretty in that I'm
not a girl he said little girls don't
look as pretty as I do
he says I'm a woman Oh dr. Tarr sounds
like an upstanding gentleman one who
respects all boundaries and is very
professional hello dr. tar came to visit
me at night he kept saying I was very
pretty then he got in bed with me and on
top of me he kept telling me not to make
any noises but it hurt he got mad when I
shouted in pain and he hit me he visits
me every night now okay I didn't exactly
expect this to be a happy story make me
pretty what oh hi what are you doing
there
mannequin I gotta make you pretty he
wants me to be pretty oh shut up I'm
busy probably important phone call but
I'm busy right now dealing with this so
do I need to find a head to put on that
why do I need to find a head to put on
that why is that an important task hello
anybody seen a disembodied head here
just randomly strewn about sitting down
maybe they run run you douche [ __ ] okay
how's normal she's still there let me
expect there to actually be anything
here huh Helen Hallie are you still
there you're probably still there aren't
there you go please go you gone are you
gone forever
oh yeah it's another thing but the
doctor does that dr. Tarr why am I not
running when I need to run she's still
there shut up I'm busy hello dr. Tarr
his flashlight doesn't go very far I
really wish I was rather at the bar dr.
Tarr are you still there did you not
make it out of the room where are these
people going I guess I shouldn't
complain okay
he gets so mad if I'm not pretty he says
my head is so small and pretty I start
bleeding after he came to visit me last
night I wish I could go home is not a
fun story is not a happy story I didn't
exactly expect these stories to be happy
but still all beside dad that's cool
not really okay wait a minute didn't I
come in this way at least I did the
night before I got in here these new
notes I kept I told the doctor I keep
getting sick in the mornings he got so
mad when I told him that he hit me in my
belly no no I know what that means and
that bad he's bad this is horrible oh
okay that's good let me just pick that
up and put it in my pocket disembodied
skull how you doing mr. skull
Oh you don't talk coz you're just a dead
object let's go you don't do nothing to
me you stay away from me no does he just
disappear are they even real my health
doesn't drop my health has been out of
constant 100 what do I do with you why
do I do with you why are you you why am
i me where's the bow there you are well
let's make it pretty oh so Freddie aah
aah Freddie what's that you're saying
you want me to run away as fast as I can
well I can oblige that weed Jesus get
out here once more I awaken this place
that can only be hell on earth there's
something holding me here it will not
let me leave in something much worth is
looking for me I must find the girl and
escape this hell oh good good great
I can't wait this is gonna be the best
adventure I've ever had in my life
Sun's up [ __ ] why God met the game
it's pretty good
I don't know what to do when the
monsters come around they just sort of
appear I turn around and run as fast as
I can and then they're not there that's
an effective system I guess maybe
because I wished upon a star for them to
go away forever they actually did or
maybe they were just trying to give me a
hug and I ran and screamed away from
them and they thought oh hello again
oh you're still here huh this is pretty
oh that is creepy that is really creepy
okay that shadow just explodes onto the
wall like that oh it's just your
prettiness leaking out don't worry about
it you're so beautiful
yeah okay I'll go this way now okay
still don't know how to sprint mechanic
works yeah I'm all tense it's good I
like it
I like it a lot and by I like it I mean
I don't really like it but I like it
okay what am I gonna do I need to escape
this hell I think that's what it said
for me to do but I'm gonna do be asleep
around corners because I'm assuming that
there's gonna be a douche bag waiting
for Jim's bag wasn't there before are
you still there son of a [ __ ] galvan me
back my baby was crying when dr. Parr
put him in a box but the crying soon
stopped when he set him on fire
why that's horrible
I hate dr. Dyer why would you do that
you're a doctor I don't care if you're
at an insane asylum why that's horrible
that's horrible no it's so bad I can't
even I can't even begin to describe how
that rates on my scale of badness bad
things there's been so many bad things
that I've seen in these horror games but
go that's bad hello who's in there
someone pretty I hope oh good it's the
baby he took my baby oh that is not cool
why am I gonna take the baby why is it
so horrifying why are you so weird okay
okay good huh worried something bad was
gonna happen
I'm so glad I'm gonna be able to get out
of here and live a happy happy life
forever and ever where am I going with
this some quote unquote babe a break no
no no no you still have fire still there
hey stop puking up blood and spring he's
still there is he still there is he a
permanent fixture as a Mizanin no she
just disappeared like everybody else did
like everybody else in my life they just
disappear hello I'm assuming I was
supposed to go this way because there
was a monster in my way oh I need to put
it in the box
who no no I now understand the horror
this year oh she said pain suffering to
have been raped by such a monster an
average child holy table take it to be a
bird alive why would you come back ah
it's so bad it's so horrible I can
imagine so horrible where do I go now I
gotta say like the monster dynamics
aren't even that great but then again
the monster dynamics aren't even the
main focus of this game like the story
is the main focus of this game and the
story is just oh I keep screaming what
he did to me and my baby but no one
cares he wants me to shut up dr. Tarr
told me I'm very pretty and then I'm not
a girl he said little girls don't look
as pretty as I do
he says I'm a woman I know what you said
before now I used to have a heart
anybody any monsters any monsters gonna
run at me menacingly any monsters gonna
call out my name well that sounds like
yeah something dr. kaar son of a [ __ ]
okay
right here out here out here out here
you still there there when do you
disappear how why who and what no you
run
thank you he told me my grandmother died
today he said she fell down the stairs
and broke her neck fell down he said it
with a smile
I know he did it he said no one will
ever come for me now he said he's going
to lock me away in a dark room where
I'll be no trouble for him ever again
when were you trouble for him what
where's the baby box that's good
familiar landmarks where am I
oh yeah oh I ran right into you who's
all right what a minute do was get as
far away from you as possible I'm gonna
get close here well I can try to come
for you I'm sorry [ __ ] oh Jesus all
the end oh good I got a loading screen
for the end why that was it God that was
such a roller coaster ride it was like
no breaks in between anything happening
oh my god
Jesus those good those an experience oh
man that's actually a lot of fun except
for the horrible horrible story that was
not fun but either way that was pretty
good oh man
I almost feel like I rushed through that
like I just blew through the entire
thing I didn't even I didn't even
explore much of the area I don't even
know if there was area to explore but
either way that was really good you can
find the link to this game in the
description below ah I guess that's it
uh-huh so thank you everybody so much
for watching if you enjoyed this video
please click the like button down below
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye-bye
how are you not dead